hello my name is Kasia converse ska I
work as a developer in Wolfram research
and I'm gonna be talking about awesome
this is also not 3d I talk about the
special point date analysis there will
be some maybe special point data but
mainly I'm gonna talk about what's on
and not the fish but the person we try
to establish and so some some background
so why really look at the Poisson when
one reason is because I actually work
presently a lot with what's on but also
we have a lot of namesakes in one
language so if you look at all the names
that would contain Poisson that's quite
a list and I have 12 probably yo version
of Mathematica has 11 but we'll get to
that and when you when you connect you
there you know outside world like
Wikipedia then you can see that actually
there's so many more things that were
named after that person in physics and
also in mathematics and and and whatnot
and so we can you know ask our entity
framework to to who this person was and
you know did he had a notable film
appearances and whatnot and this is this
is this is what's on he unfortunately
died before the the golden Hollywood era
but he was a mathematician and I would
say he was quite a prolific one we don't
have here really his major
accomplishments but you know if you can
look at the number of things named after
him
it's it's it's worth exploring some of
the some of the features so I'm gonna
start with the thing the basic one and
the most known one which is a Poisson
distribution and that was actually
derived by another French mathematician
the mom but i was popularized by poisson
who was using it in a wrong way to prove
something wrong and in like century
later so we have a poisson distribution
that's our symbol
and it is defined with one parameter
usually denoted mu and this is this has
to be positive real and this is the mean
of the of the of the distribution so
this gives us the likelihood of a given
number of independent events that happen
in in some in some fixed interval at the
known average rate and so that was
originally used you know looking at the
deaths of soldiers in army by the you
know being kicked by the horse we don't
really do this now but we have lots of
things to to to model with so the
internet traffic one call arrivals any
rivals actually scoring soda sporting
events and and such so this tells you
what it is represents the Poisson
distribution with mean and so when you
look at the the property skew the mean
and variance you see that they're the
same so the problem kind of here is to
keep in mind that if you increase the
rate the the mean so the kind of the
rate you also increase the variance of
the of the distribution but can model
independent events and so what I would
like to kind of so let's see if we can
model accidents in in Champaign and the
right here it's completely fake okay I
have no idea how many accidents are in
count so please bear with me that it's
just just illustrative example we can
sample from this distribution using the
random variate I am NOT printing all of
those 365 events but we can you know
plot it using for example this plot and
the orange line is that is the rate so
they oscillate the number of events of
slides around the mean what is nice
about the Poisson distribution is that
if you have two random variables that
are independent and both Poisson
distributed their sum is also Poisson
distributed and the mean is the sum of
the means of each of those so now if I
take the accidents in Urbana the Queen
city of Champaign and then I want to
find out what's the sum of all the
accidents
in our two cities I can model this by
another Poisson with the new parameter
and so we can simulate that what compare
so the simulation was from the new
distribution but what I can do also is
to simulate independently the data or
you know from both a distribution of
both cities and then use estimated
distribution to feed the new person into
this you know to the sum of those two
data out of curiosity the difference of
two Poisson distributions has its own
symbol in Wolfram language it's a scale
of distribution the mean is the
difference of the means and the variance
is the sum of the other variances so if
I want to look at the difference of the
of the accidents between the the
champaign-urbana this is more less what
it might look like
okay so what's on distribution we just
have a bunch of events happening and we
don't worry about their you know timing
if you want to worry about you know how
they happen in time meaning that I'm
looking at say arrivals to to somewhere
that means that I'm looking at those in
in in their order in time and we have
another model which is the Poisson
process and we enforce on process we
model the the counts of independent
events P that are order in time so I
defined the Poisson process
what is nice that for the Mafia folks
that this is the process that has
independent increments so basically what
happens you know what happens now
doesn't it doesn't really depend on
their on their on the paths so the
Poisson process gets its name because
the the slides distribution for for each
time is actually a Poisson distribution
that depends on the on the parameter of
the process and also on the time at
which we take the slice so now if we
will go back to our accidents and who
like to now model this accidents in
hours knowing the daily right
to find the rate per hour and defined a
new process then I can simulate possible
count say for two days so up to 48 hours
using a random function and the result
of this is a temporal data and this is
well as what it can look like in a
simulation if I have right now
created data that has many many powers
one thousand powers then we can look at
slides distributions this is when it
pops
so after 24 hours it's light it's going
to be some distribution at this point
this is a slice through the data through
the path there are many parts of the
processes and the object here is a data
distribution there are some properties
of this data distribution and for us the
important is the domain which would
extract the data so I can compare the
PDFs from the simulation in the process
slice distribution we can compute the
mean and this is the slice the data and
then we can take this slice and then
feed the Poisson distribution into this
into this data but because we know what
it is we can also figure out by by by
you know an analytically what's that
what's the distribution it's not the
best estimation this is maybe not the
biggest sample also the the times in in
this Poisson process are assumed to be
coming from exponential distribution
they're assumed to be independent so if
I take the the original data which is
our here
simulation for the 4/4
for the for champagne and I take the x
that's just from a from a single path
okay then I can estimate this financial
distribution but we also know exactly
what's the model for this
distribution of the of the arrived
arrival times in this way so that was a
process that had a constant rate okay we
have an expansion of the Poisson process
ago from language that allows you to
specify your custom boring rate which is
going to be varying in time and this is
inhomogeneous Poisson process and since
when I was talking about accidents the
next logical step is actually going to
emergency room so what I want to show
you this example when we have a time
series of the number of patients
arriving to emergency room per hour in
in a 24 hour cycle so this is the
arrivals this is how it looks like on
the plot and I think that actually
better visualization is to Huckaby the
sector chart and to see that you know
people going for lunch and on lunch hour
get into some trouble and then people
leaving work will cause some troubles
and then when people sleep actually we
don't have many patients at the
emergency room so that seems logical and
plausible you know average rate for such
such event so what I'm gonna do here
it's to define the the rate function for
my inhomogeneous Poisson process using
interpolation and then find a model
putting in this interpolating function
defined on from the from date for the
time series we can then simulate and
kind of see the blood dots are the
that's going to be the original
accumulated data and all this kind of 15
lines are our simulations for for this
process we can then work with this model
so maybe you can ask them what's the
probability you know that the number of
of of patients arriving between 2 a.m. 3
a.m. it's at least 10 right so not so
much we can also ask what's the expected
number of patients arriving by by 6 a.m.
32 people right so that's gonna be from
from midnight in this model so see that
the slice I'm using here the slice and
then I can work with the probabilities
and expectations like of any
distribution the next object object
involved from language I would like to
present is the compound was on objects
and in this in this model basically we
start with the process and then we do
not derive the distribution from this so
compound poisson process
it's another extension to Poisson
process but in a different way
we are having kind of the same arrivals
were the same the same rate but the the
what we are accumulating are actually
independent jumps from any distribution
so before in a Poisson process we were
accounting so we were kind of
accumulating once and in this case the
jumps might have actually a value that
might be a random variable coming from
an a a univariate distribution so this
is an example and might look like so I
have a compound poisson process with
right ten the arrival rate so the jumps
you know happen with the times of
exponential distribution with parameter
ten and then the jam size is the normal
they're normally distributed and here
the the mean 0 and standard deviation 1
if I put Bernoulli distribution of
parameter 1 we get the equivalent to the
Poisson process itself they have the
same size distributions and an example
for such a use so for example we are
having a you know online porch purchase
system that you know the prices that we
add of items that we add to the online
basket follows a viable distribution and
we cannot finalize the order until it
exits the
dollars and you know this is this is my
my model compound poisson process with
quantity distribution in dollars but
already this is a viable distribution so
I have a quantities distributed
according to viable distribution it's
defined that simulate see how this look
like so the black line here it's the the
mean and the orange one is that is the
$50 kind of our you know limit so we
want to kind of see right where we stand
after the two weeks so that's the the
mean value of the of the simulation
after the 14 days so now because we are
often interested in what's the
distribution of the slice from this
process we have the compound poisson
distribution that describes exactly the
distribution of the slice for the single
time so after you know 11 days say
that's going to be again the quantity
distribution because i defined as jumps
actually using dollars of the of the of
the compound the compound poisson
distribution with all this information
inside so the the rate and and then the
distribution so i can again simulate
here and then we can compare the means
so you can see that the first meanings
of the distribution so we know you know
the distribution second is the
simulation from the distribution and
there are the last one is actually the
simulation from the process and so this
is the the slice of the process so
unfortunately there is no closed-form
for analytic formula for the PDF but
because we can simulate between kind of
see what's the shape and then we can
again compute numerically some
probabilities so that's going to be
probability that we finalized and over
there within 11 days that's less than
than 1/2 or can have a probability of
you know finalizing the order within 20
days
which is more more likely so why I am
kind of obsessed with what's on a little
bit is because one of the things that we
are looking at is is the spatial spatial
data and one of the major objects and
models in this in this in this theory is
the person point process and so this is
a this is a example of the of the
spatial process that's gonna model
uniformly and independent independently
distributed locations in space and that
means that any two disjoint regions the
number of points if I if I simulate this
over some region and I take two sub
regions the number of points in any of
these sub regions it's a random variable
and they're both independent and each of
these variables actually it's as a
Poisson distribution so this is this is
our our model and it's gonna depend on
two parameters mu which is the intensity
and then dimension in which we are so
for example the the two dimensional
process it could be with intensity forty
and then to our dimension the intensity
it's gonna kind of tell you how many
points you're going to end up because
the thing is that that when we when
you're looking at at this process we
don't really know how many points we
have in any region a priori right is
this intensity that the government's did
how many you know how many points are
yeah they will yes and so if if I define
some region city just the rectangle
which is actually a square and when I
simulate the number of points in in this
in this space we're gonna have I'm gonna
have again new object and new simulating
function and also new container
the data so this is our special point
data that was really a bit too shy to
come and be its own star of its own talk
but this is a this is a little preview
that that we are we're kind of working
towards the special you know data
analysis and special data models and so
despite the the same intensity if I
simulate this again I will get I mean
you kind of see here data points in this
in this blob the first information is
the data ball so if I evaluate this
again this number of points will change
and so the number of points in this
whole region is governed by the Poisson
distribution so so then the pattern
basically also changes with each
simulation so there will be some
properties of the special point data
that I will not elaborate on the total
of them but one of them is we would like
to know the point counts so we can
actually extract this from the data we
can like in the in a standard temporal
processes we could have multiple paths
in this way we can also have multiple
configurations for the special points so
this is the thousand configurations this
is a new thing coming here from for all
our kind of blobs that in the data it's
too large it may not be automatically
safe to the notebook but you can store
it by just one click and that would also
happen in people use temporal data just
just heads-up so here would I what I
have I extract the point count but
because I had so many realizations of of
this patterns that actually gonna have
it's gonna be a list of length thousand
so for each of these realizations and
you can see you know first five you know
they're gonna be around kind of values
but what is more interesting is then we
can actually analyze the the histogram
and then you know analyze the
distribution and as I said this is
governed by the way the Poisson
distribution so you want to fit a
Poisson distribution into this
into the sizes so this point counts what
we can do it's to pass the goodness of
fit using distribution feed best and I
would like to point out that the
significance level is 1000 and I I did
it because of I know what add water is
gonna talk in a new future about
p-values in the significance level and
we should use much lower significance
lever to improve our test so that's the
comparison with the with the PDF this is
from the the PDF of the estimated model
we can also do this for a different
region right so this random point
configuration takes region right so here
I would like to do this on a unit disc
and then estimate that again the Poisson
distribution
that's the goodness of fit for this and
so question is what's that what's the
formula so if what we can do here this
is a theoretical analytical you know
approach new symbol and end point count
distribution applied to a special
process okay and applied to a region I
would like to know what's the
distribution of the number of points
from this process on this region so that
gives us the Poisson distribution for x
miu okay the regional measure for our
region which was the the rectangle it's
four so that kind of gives away a beat
what's the formula if I have a disc
it's the Poisson distribution with 5
times meal the region measure it's it's
I so basically the the formula depends
on the I mean the the the distribution
of the point count if it was on
distribution when the mean is the MU
times the measure of the region data
claim that I made at the beginning of
this model was that the counts of points
in two different disjoint regions are
independent so we can also try to
ascertain this via you know sampling and
some
so I create two sub regions of my
original rectangle and then I sample you
know so I have a sample one which takes
that the point count so you know this is
the same property but then I give a Sur
give a second argument which just means
okay give me the point count of this
data only over this region and then we
can test if this samples are independent
using the independence test and the test
conclusion not rejected so that's a good
sign
and we can also compute this
analytically from the model so because
our regions were disjoint we end up with
product distribution in which we assumed
that in this in this product
distribution that both all the
components coming in a product
distribution are independent
distributions independent that they
describe independent variables so that's
us thank you and there are any questions
so I have time plans
[Applause]